number one reason why I don't support
today's educational system is because
there's no debate everybody has to
everybody who sits together and sits
there and they agree and that's it you
know we bring people here from the left
from the right my favorite conversations
sometimes are people I disagree with
literally my favorite conversation of
the timore are people I disagree with
and we dis I mean think about it he
doesn't see the same as me he doesn't
like if you're just sitting there
everybody's kissing each other's butt
and it's Echo chamber where are we how
are we moving forward nobody's bumping
heads to figure it out because that
they're going to think they're the way
that they're going to think you're going
to way they're